irán a dicho desde un comienzo que es
eeuu el que tiene que dar el primer paso
y levantar las sanciones económicas
impuestas por el gobierno del
expresidente donald trump cuando se
retiró de este acuerdo nuclear en el
2018 pero también ha dicho en el pasado
que eeuu tendría que compensar
económicamente irán por las pérdidas
económicas ocasionadas por estas
sanciones económicas que ellos
consideran ilegal pero muchos analistas
piensan que hay muchísimos discursos que
tendrán que derrumbarse antes de llegar
a un acuerdo y eeuu volver a este
acuerdo nuclear y levantar las sanciones
y es que washington también ha dicho en
el pasado que es irán el que tiene que
dar el primer paso y volver a cumplir
todo lo acordado en ese pacto nuclear
firmado en el 2015 sin embargo
muchísimos analistas y especialmente
técnicos aseguran que habrá que hacer
acuerdos conjuntos y escalonados para
que ambas partes puedan volver a este
acuerdo y volver a reactivarse ayer el
director de la organización de energía
atómica en irán ali-akbar salehí
en la red social clubhouse estuvo
hablando con algunos periodistas locales
y dijo que él era optimista y que no se
negaba a una negociación coreografiada y
escalonada para volver a reactivar este
acuerdo nuclear y para entender estas
diferentes posiciones dentro de irán hay
que entender la disputa con los más
radicales que se niegan a cualquier
acercamiento con eeuu